I'm an atheist uh with an intense
interest in religion I actually read the
entire Bible this year just because I do
stuff like that and I never actually
read it from beginning to end um then I
read the Quran because you know and I'm
going to try to do the Book of Mormon
but you know well they started hey
you're so fascinating
um do you recommend doing that I think
you should
um just to know because it's such a
touchstone
um in in the way people talk about
things it can get pretty tedious but I
even made myself read through all of the
very specific instructions on how tall
the different parts of the temple need
to be and how long the garbs need to be
and what shape they need to be and what
like and those go on a lot
um there that it surprisingly
surprisingly big chunk of Exodus
um I I thought that was more like in
Leviticus and Deuteronomy
um but then you get to books like job
you know wow I mean job is such a read
and no way job originally had that
ending like job is basically it starts
out as this perverse bet between god
um and Satan about whether or not they
can actually make a good man renounce
God and initially they can't it's all
going very predictably and then they
finally really tortured job
and he turns into the best
why is God cruel how could God possibly
exist How could a kind God do these
things and he beats he turns into like
the best lawyer in the entire world and
he defeats everyone all the people who
come to argue with him he he argues the
pants off of them and then suddenly at
the end God shows up and he's like
um well you know uh I am everywhere and
uh it's a very confusing answer he gets
an answer kind of like I am there when
when when lionesses give birth and I am
there and by the way there's this giant
monster Leviathan that's very big and
it's very scary and I and I have to
manage the universe and I'm kind of like
God are you saying that you're very busy
is that it it it it it is that
essentially your argument to job and you
don't mention the whole you don't
mention the whole kind of like that I I
have a bet that's why I was torturing
you that doesn't come up and then at the
end he decided God decides like job's
like Oh no you're totally right I was
totally wrong uh sorry
um and I and God says I'm gonna punish
those people who tried to argue with you
and didn't didn't win so
um so he gets rid of the I don't know
exactly what he does to them I don't
remember
um and then he gives job all his money
back and all and it makes him super
prosperous and I'm like no way that was
the original ending of that book like
because this would like this was clearly
loved novel that they were like but I
can't have that ending okay so so so
yeah so it's a long way of saying I
actually think it's worthwhile uh some
of it was you're always kind of
surprised when you end up in the part
like um
there are parts of it that will sneak up
on you kind of like Isaiah has a trip
um Ecclesiastes Depeche Mode foreign